transformation videos are all the rage
on youtube and recently mr who's the
boss did a hundred day body
transformation let's see which one of
these methods is scientifically proven
and which ones are not
100 days ago i challenged myself to a
fitness transformation this was me every
day i was sleeping just four hours a
night walking an average of just 2000
steps drinking four cups of caffeinated
tea okay so there's a lot happening
right off the outset what's my feelings
on transformations i think they're great
as long as you're doing them with the
mindset that you're transforming to
create a healthy lifestyle otherwise
you're going to find yourself in this
yo-yo dieting crash dieting phase losing
weight gaining weight losing weight
gaining weight and that's problematic
because fat almost has like a memory so
once you have it it comes back very
quickly sleep four hours a night is
terrible you're gonna suffer the effects
of that just several days in and i'm
talking about shot productivity
creativity metabolism energy levels
everything everything's gonna struggle
there steps it depends what else you're
doing for exercise you know people say
10 000 steps that's also kind of
overstated caffeine 44 milligrams not
really a problem so i committed to
making 10 key lifestyle changes to see
if i could turn this all around i'm
curious what these 10 key lifestyle
changes are because so many people
especially influencers fall into fads
that they think are healthy but just
result in short-term
goals being achieved like hitting a
certain number on a scale but hitting a
certain number on a scale with an
unhealthy habit is not something that's
good for your health the first five days
were horrible i dropped immediately from
three to four cups of tea and coffee a
day to zero and while i did think this
would be challenging i had no idea that
i'd be practically unable to function
without it it's pretty interesting that
even with such a small amount of
caffeine in his diet he was already
feeling the effects of that the common
thing that we hear is if you quit cold
turkey any kind of caffeine substance
you start developing headaches usually
we theorize this is because the blood
vessels in your brain start to expand
because caffeine actually constricts
blood vessels and when they're allowed
to expand when that happens in your head
it creates a headache sensation and what
made this slightly harder was the fact
that at the same time my gym regimen had
just tripled in intensity yeah so if
you're increasing activity and at the
same time decreasing caffeine that's
going to be quite hard because remember
what caffeine does is it fights off
fatigue by blocking adenosine receptors
throughout the day you form more
adenosine as a result you feel more
sleepy as the day goes on now the way
that you can clear this outside of
ingesting substances like caffeine is by
taking naps or by sleeping a good
night's sleep i was running at every
possible opportunity literally until i
could not take another step that's a
problem when you start over training
when you haven't been training for a
long period of time that is going to be
extremely problematic because it's going
to raise your risk of developing an
injury once you get injured you're going
to stop working out and it's going to
damage your ability to reach your goals
in general when you are sedentary for
long periods of time your ligaments get
weaker your muscles get weaker and it's
usually not the big muscles that suffer
so you feel okay it's the small
stabilizing muscles within your low back
your hips your knee that really give you
that support when you're taking an
uneasy step when you are fatigued when
you aren't able to oxygenate your body
because you're huffing and puffing plus
i was making myself do 25 minutes of
fast walking at an incline every evening
on top of that the fast walking on an
incline is great because that
essentially puts your heart rate and the
blue zone uh like an ideal fat burning
zone and it won't stress you out so that
you can continue doing longer sessions
like this it's actually a great way to
build up an aerobic base the scales were
saying 83.8 kilos and 20.3 fat a lot of
the weight that you lose initially
usually happens to be water weight when
you start exercising quite heavily also
it depends on what time of the day
you're weighing yourself ideally this is
uh right after using the bathroom in the
morning naked because
that allows you to be the most
consistent over the next couple of weeks
as well as all the other stuff i started
to properly turn my attention to the art
of meditation from everything i'd heard
about meditating i knew that this was
going to be the key to reducing my
overall stress levels meditation
mindfulness is extremely powerful you
don't have to sit cross-legged with your
fingers touching in order for it to be
effective there's multiple ways an
individual can be mindful be present in
the moment or meditate for some that
means sitting in a quiet room for others
it could mean people watching at the
coffee shop it's really just about being
present in the moment because a lot of
times our anxieties will take us either
to the future or to the past both places
that we don't have control over so by
being in the present and understanding
you have control over the given moment
does reduce stress levels we have seen
this in good quality scientific research
but the other side to this coin is the
eating at the point where i decided to
make this change i was eating horribly
eating junk food had essentially become
my way of pushing myself to work harder
eating junk food can become an addiction
like anything else that is inherently
rewarding to the
reward center of your brain you eat junk
food dopamine gets released other
feel-good neurotransmitters get released
and you keep doing it when you're
stressed it's basically a form of
self-medication but an unhealthy way of
self-medication just like how we have
healthy and unhealthy coping mechanisms
this challenge really forced me to get
creative with my recipes i was really
craving pancakes obviously i couldn't
make myself the full fat version but
that allowed me to figure out a recipe
that was pretty lean very quick and
really tasty when served with some
blueberries and a bit of honey the idea
is to create a healthy relationship with
foods and to control and stop yourself
from eating out of control and that will
go a long way to keeping you healthy
everyone is going to eat something
unhealthy every now and then it's very
hard for most people to be perfect all
the time and it's not even something
that most doctors would recommend
because in medicine seeking perfection
ultimately yields negative outcomes in
many cases because the body is firmly
placed in a state of homeostasis which
means balance not perfection by this
point i can actually feel like i was in
better shape i felt lighter i felt more
agile not to mention that my weight was
now sitting at 81 kilos which isn't even
close to actually factoring in the full
difference because as well as losing the
fat i was putting on muscle at the same
time so even with all these minor
stumbles i had with my diet i think the
fact that i wasn't too hard on myself
when i had to be a bit unhealthy meant
that i never felt like it was all over
or what's the point anymore see this is
a good example of not being afraid of
taking three steps forward and one step
back and still seeing that you're making
progress because very often i see
patients fall into this cycle where
they're doing well they're trying to be
as perfect as possible then one thing
goes wrong because they're in a place
where they can't eat or there was a
temptation they can't eat healthy and
there was a temptation they say oh i
need to punish myself i need to feel
shame i need to feel remorse and then
when they feel that way they want to eat
more unhealthy foods and then they go
back and fall into their cycle of eating
unhealthy whereas if they take the
opposite approach which mr who's the
boss here took and say okay but i'm
still two steps ahead so i can continue
on this journey keep crushing it even if
i took three steps back i'm still ahead
from where i was last week so i'm gonna
keep pushing on that's where you get the
best outcomes it's like really having
the stamina to keep going forward and
stay motivated three months ago i got
myself this standing desk and i spent an
average of four hours per day working
from it
i could not recommend it more because
it's not just that you stand and you
keep your core active but you also find
that you move your legs more your arms
more and you're just generally active
for four more hours a day which is
enormous and this board that i've been
using spoiler alert for everyone
watching this video
i have the same thing underneath my desk
and i don't use it uh just under my
sanding desk here while i'm standing but
also while i'm sitting right now it
actually allows me to keep my feet busy
and studies have shown that those who
like tap their feet and especially when
you have something fidgety like this
actually burn more calories throughout
the day so i'm with this type of advice
here and then every now and again i've
been swapping it out for this vibration
plate which basically exercises my body
for me okay i don't know
quick fixes gimmicks uh cool if you
enjoy them not mandatory by any means
like one thing i used was the slender
tone belt that shocks your abs into
contracting many times very quickly this
is where like we get into the the hacks
the gimmicky stuff this is the stuff
that i think most people do not need and
i think hyper optimization and hyper
focusing on these results will actually
yield worse outcomes in the long term
because my job as a doctor is not to
give you the best transformation 100
days but to help you live 100 healthy
years because i could easily strap on a
bunch of these things and make your
quality of life absolutely terrible and
drive up your anxiety so high all the
potential benefit of these gadgets end
up backfiring one of my other
resolutions was to install a water
reminder app on my phone that pings me
every two hours to make sure i drink i
think this is another gimmicky thing the
majority of people don't need a reminder
like this because what ends up happening
and i can tell you this as a physician
with many years of practice you develop
alarm fatigue where you get so many
notifications especially ones that
aren't super urgent like this one that
you end up ignoring it once twice three
times and then you forget all about it
its value becomes meaningless to you i
thought this was genius i thought this
was going to solve my hydration problems
forever what hydration problem is he
having i'm curious because carrying a
water bottle with you will inherently
remind you to drink and that you
probably don't need a reminder in your
phone for that it did give me a nudge at
the beginning but by the time we're
approaching week 10
the regularity of it almost made me
start to just tune out the notification
it's like we know what we're talking
about in healthcare that said the
biggest thing that was actually a game
changer was just making sure that i
always had a full vote bro this is
hilarious it's like no that can't be i
did my first time watching this
recognized
it's made me feel less hungry and even
more awake and he's right here in saying
that because when you start developing
mild to moderate dehydration your
metabolism does start to suffer so
keeping it in a healthy range which
again doesn't take a lot of work doesn't
take a meticulous tracking will help you
get to and stay at a healthy weight it
was at around day 75 three quarters
through the challenge where i actually
started to notice that i was also
getting much stronger i was lifting
about 80 percent more than when i
started yeah the biggest joy that people
get from weightlifting is seeing that
progress no matter if you lift light
weights for higher reps or heavy weights
for lower reps you're gonna see progress
go up the most important thing when it
comes to weightlifting in order to see
improvements is consistency and injury
prevention i cannot tell you how many
people stop their weight training
journeys because of injuries usually due
to incorrect form or ego lifting which
is when you put too much weight on that
you're incapable of handling and end up
hurting yourself not to mention that
while at the start i was planking for
about a minute ago by this point i was
becoming able to do three minute play
that's really good i can't do a three
minute playing shout out to him by the
time we got to day 85 my sleep was
drastically better than the 28 i was
being scored when i started this change
i was now regularly hitting 70 to 80
sleep quality which was already a vast
improvement if you sleep the consistent
number of hours of sleep per night at
the same time of day and you're sleeping
eight hours a night eleven to seven and
you keep doing that every night eleven
seven eleven seven eleven seven and you
feel good and you don't have daytime
someone once where you feel like you're
sleepy you're not waking up feeling
exhausted you don't need things to tell
you your sleep quality because here's
the problem we've actually done research
with this we've told certain
participants even after they had a good
night's sleep that their quality of
sleep was bad and we compared them with
people whose sleep quality was actually
bad and we told them that it was good
and the outcomes of how they performed
actually ended up almost switching
because these individuals were so
affected by the numbers they saw in apps
like this that it didn't even matter
that they got good quality sleep so i'm
really hesitant to use apps like this
that aren't carefully clinically
monitored and i see so many glitches in
these apps that i don't want them
guiding my patients in general now if
you're enjoying it and it's something
you do for fun that's fine but be
careful making health decisions off apps
like this but then i found this product
it's an air filtration unit that
effectively just sucks in all the
allergens the dust and the pollen that
have been restricting my breathing at
night okay so those particles are not
necessarily restricting his breathing
what happens when you get an air
purifier like that usually with a hepa
filter it clears out the allergens that
cause your body to have an allergic
reaction within your airways leading
them to swell and block airflow or
create a constriction in the airflow as
a result it feels like you can't breathe
but it's not actually the particles
blocking you up as if it's a plumbing
system and i would actually recommend
that people with allergies or people who
end up mouth breathing get a humidifier
in their room as well it allows for your
mucous membranes to stay moist when
they're moist you're more likely to be
comfortable sleep throughout the night
and not wake up from a dry mouth and
also it prevents cracking of those
mucous membranes which can lead to
infections and that leads us to the
results it looks great i'm not averaging
just under eight hours of sleep a day my
daily step count perfect 13 000 my
caffeine is leveled out to about one cup
of tea per day and that's for weight 79
kilos with a 16.9 percent body fat
check out the fitness mistakes my
patients make get educated as always
stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you